the biggest money fight out there for
you is probably
you and logan
would you want to do that or would it
get too competitive or i'm not going to
allow that
dad
are you greg schultz i'm greg i know
greg paul greg boss
but go on answer it first yeah go on
that you're so right me and my friends
were talking about this the other day
that that is the the biggest money fight
out there and logan and i talk about it
all the time
parents don't want us to do it they're
like absolutely not you know why would
you do that the klitschko brothers never
fought the charla brothers haven't
fought the list goes on and
i think
logan and i like to make history
and douche it differently and spin the
narrative and i think for that reason
the fight one day will happen i mean
it's a whole different thing but i
remember tennis if venus and serena
played
everybody's watching that [ __ ] and this
is boxing like you said everybody has to
watch fighting yeah
and why not you know well
that's why i'm down
because
he would be the one that would have to
deal with that for the rest of his life
poke his belly button yeah yeah
this is wallpaper payback right here bro
yeah so if he's down you know like i i
talked about let's just say and it's
boxing anything can happen yeah if if my
own brother knocks me out i'm perfectly
fine with that really if he's used to it
he's a younger brother
if if yeah i knock out him which is more
likely to happen right
um just because
logan i love you but
he's never won a fight
wow
that's a factual statement that's not
really an insult
even though you hadn't winning all eight
rounds
eight rounds against floyd al said he
won one time
yeah but technically um yeah how many
how many rounds do you think he won
really i don't even remember to be
honest with you what my score was
probably like six to two five to three
but i you know who knows maybe i was
biased i don't know but keep going but
keep going i doubt it
but
yeah he would be the one that would have
to like accept that you know bro i've
been boxing for two years straight now
while he's been
you know doing his lollygagging
podcast
and i'm not i'm not hating on it i'm
just saying i've been more dedicated
than this nft he's into nx exactly he's
crushing it your favorite word is
probably n the n word
miles calm down that's why you bought
them
[Laughter]
okay but
but
i would really want to sit down with
logan ahead of that and be like yo
can we actually come out of this
peacefully is that because you guys
weren't always close yeah exactly but
and that's a slippery slope right um
so i just wouldn't want to go back to
that like it wouldn't be worth it if we
couldn't
both be civil regardless of the outcome
right because you said for two months
promo i'm gonna make your life hell
and you could do that knowing it's all
in good fun but it will be it's rough
but it's also probably i don't know 200
million
yeah that's what i told my mom i said
well mom i want my kids to drive
mercedes
mercedes benz you you already had that
much yeah you got that you made a lot of
money
yeah i'm going to help you with your
finances
it's like 40 000 for a mercedes you get
the c-class used you're like 25 yeah